Good morning everybody.
In the 100 years between a d 98 and Adj 192 Rome had five emperors,
Trajan,
Hadrian and tonight as pious Marcus Aurelius and comedies six if we count Lucius
verus who was co emperor with Marcus Aurelius for several years in the 50 years
following the death of the last of the Severin emperors,
a young man by the name of Alexandra saveras who died in 235 a de Rome had 20
acknowledged emperors and many more pretenders to imperial power.
Rarely did anyone hold on to power for more than a few years and some of them
lasted only a matter of months.
I like to think of the emperors as changing as quickly as the seasons in the
third century,
a d any wrong move led to assassination and replacement,
not by the Senate,
but by the provincial armies,
by the provincial armies.
Civil wars were extremely commonplace in the third century,
a d and it was a very bad time for the Roman emperors who could literally be
stabbed in the back at any moment.
And many of them were,
the Roman frontiers were in danger.
The economy was in shambles and the vast bureaucracy was also a suffering
significantly in the third century,
a d largely because of a lack of central control in view of this chaotic
situation.
There was very little time to build buildings,
which is obviously what's significant to us in the context of this course in in
many ways.
I think one can describe Visa v Architecture,
the third century D as essentially a wasteland and architectural wasteland.
There were no forums in the third century and there were no basilicas and there
were no baths.
We will see that the major project,
uh,
in the third century,
a d was not,
not unexpectedly given this situation,
a major defensive wall that was the main architectural commission in the third
century,
a d and it's with that wall that I want to begin today.
The so called a really and walls.
Uh,
before I do,
I just want to give you a glimpse of two of those 20 acknowledged emperors who
made their way through the third century,
had the boy Emperor Gordian the third on the lefthand side of the screen and the
more mature Emperor poopy anus who was co emperor with a man by the name of
Belle binus for a very short time.
And in fact,
just to give you a sense of the flavor of the third century,
uh,
both of them were dragged from the palace not too long after they had a ascended
to imperial power murdered and their bodies tossed in the Tiber river.
If you look at these two portraits,
one of the boy ampere and one of the more mature emperor,
even though many,
many years separate them in chronological age,
I think you will see if you look at the way in which these portraitists
represented their eyes in the likenesses of these two individuals and these
official portraits of Gordian and if poopy anus,
I think you'll see,
if you look at those eyes,
those eyes reveal,
uh,
the concern that these emperors had for the state of the empire,
during the third century had a concern that was extremely warranted,
obviously.
So again,
I want to begin with the only significant architectural project in the third
century Aidy in Rome.
And that is this great defensive wall system called the [inaudible] walls.
Uh,
the really in walls were built for two main reasons.
One,
because the earlier walls,
the so called Serbian walls,
which we studied at the very beginning of the semester,
which date to the republic,
378 BC is when they were dedicated.
So way,
way back in the beginning of our discussion of Roman architecture,
you'll remember that those Serbian walls,
and I can show it to you with this,
uh,
this plan here of the walls.
Uh,
during ancient Roman times,
the Serbian walls encircled just the seven hills of Rome.
So the central area here where we see the Palatine,
the capital line,
the Caelian,
uh,
the queer and it'll hill,
that was the location of that original Serbian wall.
As the city grew,
as the population grew,
as more people were brought back to roam through,
uh,
the various wars and through the enslavement of large numbers of people,
the city grew significantly in size.
Uh,
and so by this time,
by the third century,
the,
the Serbian wall was essentially useless to protect roam from those barbarians
that we're literally at the gates at this particular point in Roman history.
So they needed to build that wall to protect the city.
Uh,
and uh,
but the other reason was because of those,
because of what was going on on the frontiers because Roman was more in danger
than it had ever been before because of the kind of political and economic
situation in Rome that I've just described.
There was a need for further stability and the need to build this second set of
walls.
Again,
the so called a real gun walls and this plan shows you how much further out they
went.
Then the Serbian walls all the way to the Tiber river.
It didn't encompass the area across the Tiber where Hadrian's tomb Hadrian's and
mausoleum the castle son Angelo is located.
But for the most part,
uh,
it did cover the main of the city.
And you can see it went far enough out that it even encompass some of the major
city roads or the beginnings of some of those major city roads.
A view of the reunion walled itself very well preserved here on the right hand
side of the screen and a comparison of them,
uh,
with the Serbian walls on the left with regard to the real Ian walls,
they are named for the emperor or religion who was emperor of Rome between 270
and 275.
And we believe that a really and began the walls either in two 70 or 271 they
were not finished by his death.
And two 75 a and they were completed by his successor,
a man by the name of Probus,
p r o B u s probus completed the really in walls and dedicated them.
Uh,
right after,
uh,
right after really Ann's death in a row in 275,
the really in walls had a 12 mile circuit around the city of Rome.
They were originally 25 and one half feet tall and there were 18 major gateways
in the real Ian walls,
18 major gateways.
I think you can see from this view on the right hand side of the screen that
the,
uh,
that the,
the building materials were concrete faced with brick,
brick faced concrete.
You see that very clearly here and of course it's,
it's important to keep in mind that that is different than what the original,
uh,
Republican walls were made out of.
Those were made out of cut stone ashler blocks.
Uh,
you see them here in this section of the survey and walls that I show you once
again,
uh,
blocks that are laid in the scheme of headers and stretchers that we talked
about at the very beginning of the semester when we discussed early Roman wall
building both in Rome and in the early colonies.
And here again,
the religion walls with their,
uh,
uptodate concrete faced with brick.
But it's a sign of the Times that scholars who have examined these bricks have
determined that they were not all new bricks,
that many of them were reused bricks from earlier periods,
uh,
from the,
from the previous,
uh,
century in particular.
And the reason for that probably has to do with the fact that again,
because there was so little architectural activity during this period,
there was simply no need to make bricks in,
in large numbers.
And when they needed them for this particular project,
they reached back and use some that had been lying around from ur of earlier
manufacturer.
So I think again,
that underscores uh,
the,
the um,
the uh,
uncertain,
uncertain of this particular period of time.
Here's another very good view of the real end walls as they look today.
Uh,
brick face,
concrete construction once again.
Uh,
and what's impressive about the religion walls is how much of them are
preserved.
When I showed you the Serbian walls,
we could only look at bits and pieces of those walls preserved in different
parts of Rome,
especially near the Ma,
the room,
a train station.
But in the case of the really in walls,
we have a very large extent of those walls still preserve today,
which is a tribute to how,
how well they were built a,
that they have stood the test of time.
And in fact,
when one visits Rome,
when you come into Rome from Leonardo Da Vinci Airport,
uh,
the first thing that you see a of the city are the walls.
You go through those walls and it announces to you of course that you are in
fact about to enter,
uh,
the city of Rome.
I mentioned that the walls had 18 gateways.
Uh,
some of them are still preserved and I sh I want to show you one of them here
just to give you a sense of what these gateways we're like,
this is the so called Puerto Apia.
It also dates to the same time as the walls 275 a d,
uh,
called the Puerto Apia because it is at the exact location of the via Apia or
the [inaudible] way in Rome.
The Ah,
the gate.
Ah,
I'm going to show you how the gate looked in the tie into hundred and 75 and
then how it was altered somewhat later.
You can see from the monument list that although it was built originally in two
75,
it was restored by two Byzantine emperors by the name of a Norris and Arcadia.
So this is in the post,
uh,
Roman period,
of Aad.
And they did that in [inaudible] 84 or one to 402.
And the gate,
as you see it today,
extremely well preserved is the gate of the restoration of the fifth century a,
whereas this view,
this restored view from Ward Perkins shows you what the gate would have looked
like in two 75 in two 75 it had to RQ weighted entrance ways.
As you can see,
well here it had rounded towers,
rounded towers,
uh,
it had small windows with uh,
occupations at the top.
As you can also see curve curvature at the top.
And then ward Perkins believes there's some controversy about this,
but he believes it was already crenelated.
Yeah,
in the third century,
a d if you compare that to the gate as restored by are notorious and Arcadia's,
uh,
you can see that they have removed one of the entrance ways.
There's a single RQ weighted entranceway now in the center of the gate.
And they have also in case the rounded towers in these square blocks,
as you can see here.
Or they've left the upper most part rounded but not the bottom part.
So they have changed it somewhat,
but I think it still gives you,
again,
a very good sense of what this gate and many of the other gates that were part
of this very important defensive wall system built in the third century,
looked like.
What we see happening toward the end of the third century.
Aad is the return of a centralized of a strong centralized government to Rome
and to the Roman Empire after the bloody third century.
Aad.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
numerous fly by night emperors as I call them here.
And the vehicle of this return of a stable government was the foundation of what
we call the tetrarchy,
the tetrarchy,
which means literally four man rule.
The tetrarchy was the brainchild of a man by the name of Diocletian.
Diocletian was a Dalmatian,
not a dog,
a,
but somebody who came from ancient Dalmatia.
Now Croatia from Dalmatia,
he was an imperial bodyguard who rose to great heights,
uh,
and eventually became emperor of Rome.
He began his own rise to power and 283,
a 283 had,
but it was in two 93 after 10 years into trying to go it alone,
that he realized that the Roman Empire had become must much too vast a for one
man to be able to govern it alone.
And he came up with this extraordinary idea,
uh,
to have four men rule.
We've seen co emperors before.
We've seen two man rule.
There was two man rule initially with Marcus really is and Lucius of areas for
example.
Uh,
but we have never before seen a four man rule,
but he felt that the empire was sprawling enough that it really needed emperors
in four different locations,
uh,
to enable the empire to be governed and to enable stability to be returned.
And that was the concept of the tetrarchy,
which again,
he founded in 293 by founding the tetrarchy,
he made himself the main emperor,
the Augustus,
but the Augustus in the eastern part of the empire.
And I'm sure he chose that because of his own,
uh,
his own roots in,
in,
in Dalmatia,
in again what is now Croatia.
He shows a man by the name of Gillary us,
uh,
to be his Caesar,
to be his second in command in the eastern part of the empire.
He's selected Maximilian Maximilian to be Augustus in the west.
And then Constancia is Cloris to be the Caesar in the West.
Can Stanzas Cloris more well known as the father of Constantine,
the great then he is as a tetrarch.
Uh,
but he again,
Constancia scores was the designated Caesar in the West order was restored
through the vehicle of the tetrarchy.
And what that means for us in this course enrollment architecture is that
stability,
returns,
that enabled major architectural commissions to once again be done both in Rome
and also around the provinces.
And particularly in the provinces,
uh,
that these individuals made their,
their capitals in a sense and where they,
where they lived and where we'll see they built their own palaces.
So when we speak of,
but when we speak of Ted target architecture,
I think we have to keep in mind that we are talking not just about the
renovation of Rome.
I mean Rome itself,
the renascence,
let's call it that instead of renovation the renascence of Rome,
Rome's rebirth,
uh,
under the tetrarchy and under Diocletian.
Uh,
but we are also talking about architecture as we'll see that was put up in the
provinces also under the,
uh,
under the aegis of the Tetra Arcs.
I want to just show you what the tetrarchy looked like and their portraiture is
also illustrative of what their major architectural agenda was.
We see a coin portrait on the lefthand side of the screen of Diocletian.
Uh,
that meant that that gives his title Augustus.
As you can see here,
a typical Roman coin profile,
a portrait that shows him with a closely crop,
military hairstyle and beard,
but the much more,
and he,
he has represented this way in his coins,
you know,
from two 83 the first decade from two 83 to about two 93.
But the,
the image that becomes the image of the Ted talks as a whole is the sort of
thing that you see here.
We begin to see with the formation of the tetrarchy representations of them as a
group.
Uh,
it's,
it's sort of one,
one for all and all for one concept,
uh,
that they are shown a in mutual support,
holding each other,
embracing each other and mutual support as they tried to restabilize the
government.
Uh,
this is a very,
this is a wonderful group portrait of the four tetrarchy.
It's done in this reddish,
purplish tone that comes from Egypt called Porphyry Por p h y r y and a stone
that we'll see used extensively in this period.
This portrait is carved out of that.
Uh,
we don't,
we have thoughts about where it might have come from,
perhaps even Constantinople,
but it ended up in Venice.
And any of you who make your way to San Marco in Venice a,
it's not immediately obvious where it is,
but if you stand in front of San Marco facing it and go off a bit to the right,
uh,
you will see this incredible,
poor for regroup,
uh,
hugging a one corner of the building over here.
Uh,
and again,
uh,
you can see them.
It's done.
What's interesting to us,
I think is the fact that it's done in a very geometric abstract style.
Uh,
it doesn't look realistic.
They are done.
They're,
their proportions are,
uh,
are,
are stumpy and uh,
they,
their bodies,
their military costumes and their faces,
uh,
seem almost more like in their bats that they were,
these Pannonian cap seem almost more like geometric shapes than they seem like
real clothing and the like.
And that is part and parcel of a certain aesthetic,
uh,
that we see developing this interest in geometric and abstract forms that we see
in portraiture.
But we also see,
which is important for us today.
We see that in architecture as well,
that interest.
And I think,
you know,
perhaps it's going too far,
but I don't think so.
I think that the,
the taste for that particular formulation I has to do in part with this,
the fact that they believe they have returned or they're trying to return
stability to the government.
So they choose these very solid geometric abstract forms to represent their
images,
be they a portraiture or be they as we'll see,
monumental works of architecture.
Perhaps.
It's not surprising to see that when Diocletian begins to put up monumental
architecture in Rome,
he chooses first public monuments,
public monuments that are going to be seen and that are going to speak to this
return of stability to Rome,
uh,
and he chooses to put them in as visible place as he possibly can.
And what's the most visible place in the city of Rome?
But the Roman forum,
the Great Forum Romana them.
So we see a Diocletian commissioning,
a monument to put up in the Roman forum.
That monument is referred to by a variety of names.
We usually call it,
and I indicated this for you on the monument lists,
we usually call it the preferred name forward is the descent monument,
the decennial monument,
but it is also sometimes called the five column monument and it is sometimes
called the tetrarch monument.
It's called the tetrarch monument because it honors the four tetrarchy.
It's called the five column monument because it's made up is we'll see a five
columns and it's called the Desenia monument because it,
it honors the destination area,
the 10 year rule of the tetrarchy,
the tetrarchy founded in two 93 the monument is put up in 303 so 10 years of
rule,
and it also honored the 20th anniversary,
the Visalia Bic,
e n,
n a,
l,
I a,
the vice Analia of Diocletian because Diocletian had become emperor into 83 so
he's,
he's lasted 20 years,
which is extraordinary considering some members of the third century only lasted
a matter of months.
He's lasted 20 years and his tetrarchy has lasted 10 years and it's time for
celebration and he puts up a major monument in the Roman forum.
Let me show you by it.
This map,
first of this plan of the Roman forum,
as it would've looked between the third century in the seventh century a d we
see a number of buildings that we have looked at together before.
We can see in the upper most part,
the top,
you Laurium the temple of Vespasian.
Uh,
we see the arch of Septum.
You severity's up here we see some buildings.
We did not talk about,
for example,
the Temple of the Divine Julius Caesar and a couple of facilities that were put
up here in the late republic and into the Augusta and finished and the Augustan
period.
The two buildings that we're going to look at today are the Senate house or the
Cory a Giulia,
uh,
but also at the raw stra or what's behind the roster.
If you see the roster there,
right in the center,
that's the,
the day is from which a major speeches were made.
If you look right behind the roster,
you will see four columns on a curve and then another column right behind them.
That is the so called four f of the so called.
Um,
if I've called a monument,
excuse me,
of,
uh,
of the tetrarchy,
that we see they're right behind the rostrum.
Now here we're looking at a Google earth image from the same vantage point that
shows us again,
uh,
the coliseum,
the Victor Emmanuel monument,
the Co,
the capital line hill,
the Palatine Hill,
the circus maximus right here,
the forum in the center.
And we can locate the five column monument by,
uh,
let me see here.
We have here,
we have the Korea.
Here we have the arches Septum,
you severities.
And then right to right next to the arch of symptom you severe as essentially to
the left of it was the location of the five column monument right behind the raw
stroke.
Now the problem is that all we have left of this,
so called five column monument,
is a single base,
one base of one of the columns.
And you can see that base it on display right in front of,
on a pet,
on a,
on a base,
right down a base and a different phase of base made out of,
um,
of uh,
a brick.
As you see here,
the base of that one column right in front of the arch of sip to me is severity
dwarfed by the arch of symptom.
You saveras.
In fact,
I'm always,
always on the lookout when I'm in that part of the forum to see if anybody looks
at the column I said nobody ever does.
They're so taken both with the,
with the [inaudible],
with the Baroque church that lies behind them with the,
with the,
uh,
Korea or Senate House that we're all going to look at today,
that they don't happen to notice this.
But that is all that survives.
So you might ask yourself,
well,
then how in the world do we know there was a five column monument behind the
roster on that?
This is one of those columns because we have a depiction of it on the arch of
Constantine,
which we'll be looking at on Tuesday,
the early fourth century Aidy arch.
One of the scenes,
uh,
that shows Constantine himself is located in the Roman forum.
And we see Constantine now headless,
uh,
with some of his attendance and other individuals standing on the roster.
Rostrum making a,
an address to the people he surrounded.
This is very interesting.
We'll talk about why next time,
surrounded by seated portraits of Hadrian and Marcus really is identifiable by
their portraits and he's making an address.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see behind him are five columns,
five columns that have a statues on top of them.
That is the five column monument that stood behind the roster.
So that combined with that preserve base gives us a very good sense of what that
monument might've looked like.
Then you may be asking yourself,
what is she talking about?
Five columns.
I mean,
there are only four tet drugs.
Is She misspeaking here?
Now I'm speaking correctly,
there were five columns.
Uh,
but one of those columns was put up to Jupiter,
Jupiter,
the head,
God Jupiter,
who was the patron God of Diocletian.
Uh,
so we see Jupiter in one column on his own back behind the others,
uh,
and then the other four columns of the tetrarchy,
each with a base with a fee with a sculptural figural decoration down below the
shaft was playing,
uh,
then then a statue of each of the four tet rocks and the statue of Jupiter on
the top.
And we think that the statue of the column and Statute Jupiter,
we're probably a little bit taller as is indicated here,
because he was after all a god a then the others.
Uh,
and you can see the way it is located behind the raw stra.
So that again,
if someone were speaking from the roster,
that this is exactly what you'd be seeing behind.
Just as we see in the arch of Constantine,
uh,
you also see its location as it faces the Temple of Divine Julius Caesar,
which is probably not a coincidence.
We do see that Diocletian tried to link himself to Caesar and others,
great leaders of the Roman past.
And then this basilica completed by Augustus.
This was very carefully chosen location,
uh,
by Diocletian to link himself after this,
after this bloody third century as I mentioned,
to link himself,
uh,
with the great leaders of the Roman past.
I can,
I want to show you quickly because this is again of course in architecture,
not in sculpture,
but I do want to show you just quickly the scenes on the base because I think
one of the interesting,
uh,
interesting detective work one can do is to try to figure out,
since we have only one base who's based,
was it,
which of the four tet trucks or was it Jupiter's base?
Uh,
and I've tried that,
played that game myself and I'll give you my idea and you'll see whether you
think it's a good one or not.
Uh,
we look at the scene at the top,
upper most part.
We're looking at the four sides of that sculptured base.
At the top you see two victories,
a with a shield.
And that shield has the word in the center destined Eylea doesn't Nalia.
That's how we know it's dedicated to the descending of the sending of
anniversary,
10 year rule of the tetrarchy.
You can also see barbarians down below.
So a reference to uh,
those who have been conquered.
And if you look very carefully,
you'll see that the figures are outlined in the way that we saw them at all
raunch and also at Santa me.
And then some of the items including the arms and armor are actually inscribed
carved on the stone directly on the stone.
So this very interesting use of outlining here,
here.
I don't think the reason for it is the same.
I don't think they're looking at at copybooks,
but rather a that there has been,
there is,
there is now an interest in this kind of outlining for effect up here we see a
sacrifice of three animals being brought in for sacrifice and the men with their
axes who are going to slit their throats.
Ultimately the sacrifice obviously in honor of this descent,
Neil Celebration,
this anniversary celebration,
uh,
Ma,
making reference to 10 year rule of the tetrarchy.
Here's the scene down here.
Unfortunately in all of these scenes where we seem to have,
uh,
the emperor or emperors,
the heads are no longer preserved.
So here we have a sacrifice seen also a sacrifice being made in honor of this
descending IOL anniversary.
But the emperor represented here who was sacrificing,
who's based,
this probably was his face is gone,
but you can see he's accompanied by Roma,
by the,
the uh,
the Senate,
the personification of the Senate by Mars,
by victory who crowns him with the wreath.
As you can see here,
and this looks like a figure of Saul,
Helios with the raid crown.
So a whole panoply of divinities with whom?
By whom he is being honored and with whom he wants to associate himself.
This is the most important relief,
I believe,
in terms of,
of speculating about whose base this might've been.
We see a four figures for adult males in the foreground with togas.
All of them had lists,
unfortunately.
Uh,
but four of them,
that's no coincidence.
All four standing there.
So while we see one of them,
this is his base,
one of them,
uh,
sacrificing here.
I guess one could argue it's Diocletian is the head of the tetrarchy.
That would be another possibility,
but the four of them represented here.
But if you look very closely,
one of them is accompanied by a child.
So my speculation would be since one of them is accompanied by a child and
since,
uh,
it is Constantine who was most well thought,
most likely to be the one to eventually succeed the Ted talks or become a
tetrarch himself,
I would speculate and it's pure speculation,
uh,
that this may have been the base of Gullah of a constant,
just Cloris of his father can stand just Cloris,
uh,
and that we,
the clue there is constant team.
Another building that Diocletian was interested in in the Roman forum in terms
of associating himself with Caesar and also with Augustus was the Senate House,
the,
uh,
Korea,
Julia.
It is called the Chorea Julia because it was actually not built in the
Diocletian Anik period.
But built initially begun by Caesar Gut begun by Julius Caesar to provide Rome
with the Senate house in the Roman Forum begun by Cesar,
uh,
and completed by Augustus after Caesar's death.
But the building was in and that's why it's named Corey Julia after the Julian
family,
uh,
that,
that uh,
Cesar and also Augustus were a part of a,
but that building the chorea Julia was destroyed,
very seriously destroyed in a fire in Rome in 283 a d.
And so what Diocletian does is he restores it between two 84.
He begins already into 84.
Well before the formation of the Tetrarchy,
uh,
anti completes it in 305,
a d this restoration,
it continues to be called the Chorea Julia.
Uh,
but it is at this point to directly sciatic building,
but one that clearly where he,
he instructed his designers to try to keep it as close to the original as
possible.
Now what you're looking at here on the right hand side of the screen is a coin,
uh,
that comes from the period of the emperor Augustus.
And it purports to represent,
I don't think there's any question that it represents a given it's inscription
and so on.
The Senate House in Rome,
as it would've looked as completed by Augustus,
and he's in fact celebrating the completion of this monument and associating
himself through this coin with his divine adoptive father,
Julius Caesar.
If we look at the form where if we look at the exterior of this monument,
as it is depicted on the coin,
you will see that it is a regular square.
The,
the front of the building is,
it looks like a square with a very large pediment at the top,
although I think that was accentuated here at size.
Uh,
in order to allow the dye cutter to include the sculpture in the pediment and
also the sculpture decorating the eaves.
We see the doorway right here.
We see there seem to be a triple window up above the doorway.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see that there seems to be a portico as series of columns that are
there to relieve the severity of the otherwise very geometrically ordered
facade.
Uh,
so that's what we,
that's what we think it looked like in the time of Caesar.
Based on that coin.
You see it over here in plan.
This is a plan of,
of the forum in Rome in the Augustan period,
a 10 [inaudible].
Uh,
we see the buildings that were there at that time.
The basilica is the Temple of Divine Julius Caesar,
the roster.
But of course without the five column monument,
no arches symptom use veress.
Uh,
but we do see the Cory and you see it here in plan as a very plain open
rectangular box in a sense.
So even in its [inaudible] and Augustan,
uh,
beginnings,
it seems to have been a very straightforward,
uh,
straight forward,
matter of fact kind of a building,
this is a restored view of what we believe it looked like after the restoration
by Diocletian.
You won't be surprised to hear that the materials were different,
that it's a building when in it's restored version.
It was made out of concrete,
faced with brick exposed brick,
uh,
so very much a building of its own time.
It would not have looked like that,
uh,
in the time of Caesar and Augustus,
but they have in every other way.
They have kept to the underlying geometry of the form to the use of the triple
window with a car,
a curved top.
As you can see here,
an RQ weighted top,
a pediment above.
We don't know whether the second version had pedimento sculpture in it or other
decorative sculpture,
the doorway down below,
but the severity of the brick faced the exposed brick facade has been alleviated
somewhat by the placement of marble revetment at the bottom part of the wall
behind,
uh,
a series of columns.
So they have kept that portico,
that set of columns to relieve the severity,
but also to make this building look as much as they could.
Like the original says,
Arion and Augustan structure,
this is what the Cory,
it looks like today.
It is extremely well preserved,
as you can see.
Yes,
it's lacking.
It's,
uh,
it's lacking.
It's marble revetment and it's lacking.
It's portico,
but in every other way you can see very well,
uh,
exactly what this building looked like in the time of Diocletian concrete faced
with brick,
uh,
with the very simple windows and this very geometric abstract,
ordering,
which again,
I believe,
you know,
I think the explanation for that is twofold.
One that they are trying to maintain the look of the original,
uh,
Julian building,
but also because this is again,
the aesthetic of the time on this decision to make buildings in a very
geometrically ordered abstract way.
I believe,
again,
to reflect the stability of their new government.
This building the Korea,
uh,
Julia owes its excellent,
excellent condition to the fact that it likes so many buildings we've talked
about this semester was reused over time.
Uh,
we know that it was turned into a church already in the seventh century BC,
uh,
that it was restored in the 12th and in the 16th century.
And I did I say seventh century BC.
If I did,
I met a d seventh century Aidy 12th and 16th centuries,
and then again in the 17th century and it was in the 17th century that it like
so many other Roman structures was transformed into a Baroque church,
uh,
by an architect by the name of Martino Long.
The younger,
I put his name on the monument list for you Martino Long,
the,
the younger,
and it was a re consecrated as Sohn Adriano St Hadrian all four.
Oh,
Romano.
It's on Adrianna.
All foreal Romano.
St Hadrian in the Roman forum was the church.
And when I say Baroque church,
I mean a baroque church.
It was d consecrated by muscle [inaudible] in the 1930s.
Miss Illini returning it to its original ancient form,
as you can see over here.
But this photograph,
uh,
shows the work that was being done in the 30s to dismiss,
dismantle this Baroque church into which the Corey I'd become,
I mean,
it's really hard to believe that this was the chorea in the 17th century,
but that's exactly what it looked like as well as in the early 20th century.
And you can see a bell tower had been added,
buttresses had been added to the structure completely and casing,
uh,
the Korea in a baroque church.
Uh,
and we see that being dismantled in this view over here.
And I have a view I can show you also have the interior.
This was the interior in the 17th century.
Impossible to,
to see,
uh,
that original box,
simple box like interior that was there in the time of Diocletian and probably
there in the time of Caesar Augustus.
So filled is it with the usual baroque paraphernalia,
uh,
of,
you know,
elaborate stucco work and angels flying to the skies and uh,
these,
you know,
not that we haven't seen this kind of thing.
And Roman architecture,
we of course have a,
but you can see that the original shape of this particular building has been
completely disguised by Martino longing.
The younger,
as he read does,
uh,
the Korea as a baroque church.
This is when,
when they took all of that a baroque accretion off,
this is what they ended up with.
This is what the Corey looked like.
Probably very similar to this.
And the time of Caesar Augustus,
uh,
what it looked like under Diocletian.
And what it again looks like today,
you can see from this,
from this view,
this very simple box,
like a shape for the interior of this structure.
Uh,
plain walls,
a coffered,
a flat coffered ceiling.
The only a,
the only light brought in by a series of very simple windows with RQ weighted
tops,
allowing light into the system and then down below and the brick facing the
concrete and brick facing exposed.
Uh,
but with the down below,
probably some marble revetment on the wall down here.
Very simple niches,
RQ,
waited and rectangular niches,
but very,
very simple ones.
And then here you see the benches,
the stone benches on which,
uh,
the senators would have sat,
when they were deliberating or stood in front of cause they got up a lot in
oriented,
uh,
but stood in front of when they delivered their speeches or,
or,
or sat.
And then down below the original,
uh,
the original marble prevented floor,
is still preserved.
And I can show you two views here and color of that floor,
uh,
to give you a sense of to all done in marbles,
marbles dot brought from different parts of the world,
but the usual colors that the Romans liked for most of their marble pavements,
a white or off white and Maroon Green and black,
but very nicely done for this.
Um,
very simple,
very geometrically ordered,
uh,
but very beautiful interior with regard to public architecture.
Diocletian also built a major bath in Rome,
uh,
following the lead of Caracalla and many emperors before him to provide for the
Roman people a place where they could go and enjoy themselves as well as learn.
Because you'll remember that by this time,
these major imperial bass structures,
and this is one of those,
uh,
place the bathing block inside a much larger precinct that included rooms around
it that served as lecture halls and,
uh,
meeting halls and seminar rooms and places for a Greek and Latin libraries and
the like.
And we see that scape scheme being used here.
The baths were built between a d 298 and 306 by Diocletian in Rome.
They're located near the train station today.
So very close to those remaining fragments of the survey and walls.
Uh,
and you see again that plan here and you see that the outer precinct has one of
these large hemi cycles,
uh,
that what may have been used for performances as you can see,
and that it is like the other,
other,
uh,
imperial Bas that we've looked at with the central bathing rooms in the center,
in axial relationship to one another and in the usual sequence.
And then with other rooms disposed around them on either side in a symmetrical
way.
We see it number four,
the Nataka Eto or swimming pool we see,
which has a scallop to the bottom side as you see it here is scalloped or the
wall is the number three is the frigging Darian,
the cold room of the Bas,
which had a triple groin vaulted ceiling.
Uh,
from there we go into the tip of Darian.
You see it here,
a small circular structure with radiating arms that give it a cross shape and
then down below a very interesting call,
Darian,
because we see that Diocletian and his architects have rejected the round called
Rem,
uh,
with the radiating alcove looking so much like the Pantheon is we discuss and
almost as large,
uh,
from the baths of Caracalla,
they've rejected that in favor of a more rectangular shape.
Uh,
that's more similar to the shape of the frigate Darian,
uh,
but with radiating apps is that have a series of columns that allow the views
and vistas from one to the other.
This is another version of the same plan from Ward Perkins.
In this particular case,
uh,
that shows again the Natacha,
the free Kadarian.
Here you can see better the way in which the circle becomes a cross shape for
the tip of Darian.
And then here,
uh,
the call and below where you can also see better,
I believe,
uh,
the columns on those alcoves that allow views of both from inside out and
outside in.
And here is still another one.
This is the one that you have on your monument list that shows you those spaces
once again from the other direction than Natacha,
where you can see very well the scallop wall,
the figure Darian,
where you can see the triple groin vault,
the tip Darian with its round shape and radiating arms.
And then most importantly,
the call Darren with probably also triple growing vaulted,
just like the free Kadarian,
but with radiating alcoves,
uh,
and then all of these other rooms disposed around them symmetrically.
Now what's very interesting also in terms of more architecture in later times is
the,
uh,
is the baths of Diocletian.
We're also a reused in,
but in this case,
not for a single building,
but for a variety of buildings,
including a major museum of a planetarium,
uh,
and also a church,
the famous Church of Santa Maria Daily Anjalee Saint Mary of the angels.
Now,
while this plan is still on the screen,
I want to show you when the Church of some,
some Santa Maria daily,
Anjali was redesigned.
And one of the redesign is,
by the way,
was Michelangelo.
When it was redesigned.
What they did was they took the alcove,
the from where we're standing,
the bottom alcove of the call,
Darian,
they use that as the curved facade of their church.
Uh,
they used the tepid Doriam as the vestibule.
They use the frigging Doriam as the main space of the church,
uh,
and also,
and they,
and,
and so that becomes the church that made that,
that bottom part of the call Darren,
the tepid Dharm and the freakatorium become the church.
And then some of these other spaces are used again for other kinds of buildings,
including the planetarium,
I call your attention,
especially to the ones at the upper right and the upper left,
uh,
both of which are an octagonal spaces,
as you can see,
comparable to earlier octagonal spaces under Nero or under demission,
uh,
and one of those rooms,
this one at the Ra to our right,
but to the left when you're facing the entrance to the church today,
uh,
is,
is still a very well preserved.
And I'm going to show you,
show you that in a moment.
First,
here's a view into the church,
into the nave of Santa Maria Daily Anjulie,
uh,
which again,
what you're looking at,
the original frigate Darian of the baths of Diocletian.
Uh,
you can see all the things one usually sees in a Doriam.
And I show you a restored view of what we think the Frigidaire him of the baths
of Caracalla looked like in antiquity.
And you can see there's a close resemblance between the,
the two.
The groin vaults are still preserved.
Uh,
we see original columns here,
granite columns with capital.
Some of the capitals are ancient,
some of them are not.
And we see a lot of color,
a justice we would've seen in the original baths of Caracalla of Diocletian.
One one difference is that we see the groin vaults in the Santa Maria daily
Anjalee are white.
And that is the work of Michelangelo.
Michelangelo decided that he wanted something much plainer,
uh,
for the vaulting of Santa Maria daily on Jelly.
And it was he who stuck oded over and no one ever dared to change,
uh,
Michelangelo's work.
But another architect by the name of Luigi,
Vaughn v,
Tele Van v.
I.
T.
L.
I love the name.
Luigi von Vitelli was at work in the Santa Maria daily Anjalee interior in the
18th century.
Precisely in 1749.
Uh,
he came in to,
uh,
to spruce up the decoration and it was bond be tele who added to the original
Roman granted,
uh,
columns,
who added these models.
You see these models pilasters I'll show you a detail of them in a moment with
their capitals,
some new capitals to match the ancient Roman capitals.
He added all lot of the stucco decoration that you see it here now.
And a lot of the altar pieces where we're put in a,
in the 17th and 18th century,
um,
to make it the church that it needed to become a,
but if I show you a detail of von be teles work,
you can see,
you know,
as you stand in Santa Maria de Leon Jelly,
one tries to figure out what's ancient and what is,
what is modern.
But you can see here what seems to be a granite shaft from an ancient column
with a new,
a Corinthian capital designed by von be telly that imitates those,
uh,
of the Roman ones that are there.
But all of this mottled work and all of the stucco decoration that you see over
here added by Vaughn v Telly in the 18th century.
But we,
you've seen enough Roman ancient Roman architecture,
especially if the baroque kind,
uh,
to know that this sort of thing did exist in Roman times.
And I think bond Vitelli has actually done a pretty good job of giving us a
sense of what the Frigidaire Doriam of these paths would have looked like in the
time of Diocletian.
Now here's the facade.
And so you see exactly what I described before.
This is one of the alcoves.
You can see the concrete brick faced a alco that they have.
I mean,
this is the simplest facade of any in Rome.
There's nothing quite like this,
but it's so typical of the Italians to make wonderful,
to take wonderful advantage of what there is.
And so in this case,
they decided best to leave it as it is.
It speaks for itself.
They just use that Alco,
they added a couple of doors,
uh,
created a niche,
slap the name Basilica,
Santa Maria daily.
Angelie on the front.
Very simply put a cross at the top.
And this became the facade,
uh,
into the church.
And it has remained this,
uh,
to this day.
Here's another view of the bads of Karch,
uh,
of Diocletian as they look today,
we're looking at the outside where we can see the outside of the [inaudible]
with its windows and it's growing,
bolting exposed on the outside.
Uh,
this is the tip,
Darian and the roofing of the tepid Darian.
And over here you can see the curved facade.
That's the part of the caldarium that survives,
uses the facade of the church.
And then as you stand here,
if you go to the right,
you can go and look at what one of those octagonal rooms it looks like today and
what they've done,
they've taken advantage.
This is a spectacular space.
This was just,
we don't know exactly what purpose is served in the bath originally.
Uh,
but it's actually a space,
it's more similar to the caldarium of car call his boss and it is to anything
else in the baths of Diocletian.
But you can see that they have taken advantage of this extraordinary octagonal
shape with radiating alcoves going back to uh,
to Nero's Domus transitory,
don't miss our area to use as a place to display some of the greatest works of
sculpture in the part of this,
these baths that now serves as a museum.
One very interesting feature though that I want to point out too,
that will become important for something later we talk about today and for
Tuesday's lecture is the fact that you do see using here windows,
uh,
in,
in the lower part of the Dome,
a windows RQ weighted windows to allow light into the system.
We see this at development in late antiquity where they moved from providing
light through the Oculus to providing light through a series of windows.
And again,
they're sophisticated enough and their use of concrete to be able to do that.
And we see that the trend Diocletian was as interested in,
um,
private architecture as he was in public architecture.
He was a man,
or you can tell a lot about him just from what I've told you.
It was very organized,
a any planned ahead,
uh,
for his own abdication eventually,
in his own retirement.
And he wanted to live ultimately back in his,
where his roots were on the Croatian,
on the Dalmatian coast.
Uh,
and he built for himself a palace,
uh,
in a place called split in what is now Croatia.
And I show you again the map of this part of the world.
If you look at,
uh,
Pola that we,
I can't reach it from where I am,
but if you look at Pola where that is and down the Dalmatian coast,
you'll see split right below that Dubrovnik is at the base.
This is actually a view I took of Dubrovnik just to give you a sense of this
part of the world.
It's magnificently beautiful there.
Uh,
and one can imagine,
um,
how,
why Diocletian was drawn to return to his homeland,
uh,
for his palace.
So we are looking here at the plan of the Palace of Diocletian,
which is extremely WellPreserved.
This is from Ward Perkins and you should be immediately struck,
uh,
by,
this palace because it,
uh,
which dates by the way to 300 to 305 a d.
Uh,
we see here,
uh,
something that I'm sure you've all noticed already and that is that he has built
this palace in the form of a Roman costume.
It's a Roman military camp.
It is a little city.
It's a city in its own right,
uh,
in the form of a Roman military camp.
Why did he do that?
That's interesting.
Well,
I think it had something to do with the fact that the structure was located on
the sea,
uh,
right off,
you know,
right out on a promontory on the sea.
Uh,
and uh,
could easily have been attacked and times were still,
he was still,
he had brought stability back.
Yes.
But he was very aware of what he had had proceeded him in the third century and
desirous of protecting himself and his possessions in his palace on,
on the Dalmatian coast.
And so he builds it in the form of a costume.
You can see all the elements of a typical Roman military camp.
Uh,
just as we saw in a city,
our city building,
urban planning from the republic on,
it's a rectangular in shape.
It has walls.
Uh,
it has watched towers.
You can see they are alternately rectangular and octagonal watchtowers.
It has entrances and exits.
It has a carto and a deck.
You Montas that at the intersection of the palace.
Uh,
you can see there are the main gateway is on the northern side.
The southern side faces the sea.
As you walk from the northern entrance,
way along the carto in the deck,
you Montas so to speak,
of this palace,
you will see that they are colonated just as they usually are in the eastern
part of the empire,
but not in the western part of the empire.
As you walk along from the entrance way,
you enter into a public court over here,
very elaborate.
That's still preserved with,
uh,
an RQ weighted Lyndell.
I'm going to show you that in a moment,
uh,
then into this domed area here with alcoves.
Uh,
but note that on either side of this,
uh,
this,
this open space with the RQ weighted lintel,
which is called the Paris style of the villa.
Uh,
you can see on one side a small temple,
which is a temple of Jupiter,
the patron God of Diocletian,
and on the other side,
uh,
a mausoleum,
an octagonal tomb.
Now that should strike you as very interesting and very unusual.
We have not seen a tomb as part of palace architecture before.
This is new to late antiquity.
This probably has to do in part with,
again,
Diocletian planning this as his place of retirement.
He knew he was gonna retire there.
He knew he was going to die there,
and he wanted to make sure that he supplied for himself a to me,
it was not going to be buried in one of these major Masalia in Rome.
He wanted it to be buried at home.
Uh,
and so he plans for this by building a,
uh,
an octagonal,
not around like Augustus in Hadrian,
but an octagonal tomb with a porch,
uh,
here in the villa.
And note that it is right across from the temple of Jupiter.
No,
uh,
no coincidence there.
Go through the domed room dome space into the private wing of the house.
You see a room here with a basilican shape.
We're not exactly sure what it was useful,
but probably some kind of reception hall.
Uh,
and then hear a series of interestingly shaped rooms.
that was where the emperors a private quarters we're located.
This is a restored view of what this fortress Palace would have looked like a
when it was built in the fourth century.
We see it here.
All of the things I've already described,
the outer walls,
the watch towers,
uh,
the,
entrance way on the north,
the colonated streets.
You can see the octagonal tomb rising up over there,
across from the temple of Jupiter.
And then down here,
the private area or the private wing.
And you can see how the southern side faces the sea.
And there seems to have been an RQ weighted lintel on that side.
We've seen that that's grown in influence and importance since it was first used
in the time of Hadrian.
Uh,
this is the poor to our area or the northern gate of the palace.
you see it in a restored view from Ward Perkins,
a rectangular entranceway lintel window,
like with greats above,
uh,
niches on either side with arcuate and pediments,
but most interestingly is the upper tier where you see a series of columns on
brackets that support arcades.
Uh,
this whole idea of arcades on columns,
uh,
you know,
began as we know later in antiquity and,
uh,
continues to be important into the late third and early fourth century.
We saw it at the forum,
Eh,
uh,
for the seven forum at leftist Magdna where you can see again,
columns as arcaded colonnade here.
We saw it in residential architecture,
Ostia late residential architecture.
Think of the house of Fortuna on an area where we have those,
uh,
that those columns with arches above them that separate the fountain court from
the trickling ium.
So I just wanted to make the point that we see it not only at Diocletian's
palace,
but it's very common in late Roman,
uh,
residential and civic architecture as well.
This is a view of the Paris style as it looks today.
Uh,
we have,
we are walking,
we've come from the North Gate,
we're walking along,
we're hitting the peristyle.
We're going to be going from the peristyle into that domed area here.
Imagine views through the columns of the Paris style,
and some of those columns are still preserved as you can see them.
The original columns views clearly of the temple of Jupiter and of the mausoleum
of Diocletian on the other side,
arcuate and lintel here inside a complete pediment.
So that scheme also used as the major decoration of the Paris style in the
palace of Diocletian.
Here's the view of what the small temple of Jupiter looks like.
We're looking at it originally had a statute of Jupiter.
Now it has a statue of Saint John the baptist,
but you can see the shape,
uh,
very much like the Korea,
a boxlike shape.
Very simple in this case,
not with a flat coffered ceiling,
but with a barrel vaulted coffered ceiling.
But again,
very simple,
very geometric.
And we can see that that barrel vault is exposed on the exterior.
We can see the shape of the barrel vault from the outside,
as well as from the inside here.
A view of the octagonal tomb,
the plan of that tomb,
and octagon with colonnade around it.
Columns on the inside radiating rectangular and curve niches,
but a porch.
The whole idea of the porch,
not unlike the Pantheon,
except that it's octagonal instead of round porch on the front.
Deep Porch,
freestanding columns,
facade orientation,
single staircase.
Uh,
so this is this,
this very similar to things that we've seen earlier.
And two quick views at one,
uh,
engraving of what the,
um,
the,
uh,
Moza Liam,
the octagonal muscle,
Liam would have looked like a with its,
you can see it's faced with stone,
with its entrance way facade and staircase.
And here you can see it as very well preserved still today in,
um,
in Split where you see the surrounding columns,
you can see,
uh,
the octagonal shape and the stonework all still very well preserved as,
as the interior,
very ornate with columns projecting from the wall supporting these projecting
and tablatures deeply drilled,
d materialized in the baroque manner,
uh,
with lots of sculptural decoration,
representations of victory and death and a victory over in hunting and uh,
and uh,
victory in war.
And consequently,
you know,
this close association is,
we've seen among all of those and then scenes of both with a portrait of
Diocletian and a portrait of his wife Prisca.
Uh,
both of those being carried in.
These reads up to the heavens by flying cupid's.
Here's another view,
perhaps a better one that just gives you some of the sense of the,
of the over decoration over ornamentation,
the baroque effects of the interior of the tomb.
So very,
very different feel to the temple of Jupiter.
A then to the tomb of Diocletian himself.
Here,
he has gone all out and commissioned the most ornate possible,
uh,
decoration.
Uh,
with all the baroque effects that we've described in two tiers for the interior
of his mausoleum.
I want to show you a succession of other palaces each fairly quickly.
Uh,
other palaces that were built during this period that may have been,
well,
we in some cases we know for sure,
but in other cases we're not sure whether they were in fact palaces for the
tetrarch cause this is the one that's the least certain,
uh,
it's a palace in the western part of the empire that we believe may have been
the palace of Maximilian Augustus in the West.
And in fact,
I should,
I should.
Yeah.
So let's look at that first and that dates as you can see from your monument
list to sometime in the early fourth century.
Aidy.
Now if you look at the plan of this quickly,
uh,
you will see that it is very,
very different and feel from an implant from the palace of Diocletian at split.
This may have something to do with the personality of Maximilian or whoever the
commissioner was a,
but it may also have to do with the fact that this is not on the sea,
but in a remote town in south central Sicily,
which was much less likely to be under attack.
Uh,
then the,
uh,
the palace,
at a split,
uh,
in fact,
as you look at this,
you must be reminded,
I'm sure,
uh,
of the,
villa of Hadrian actively.
It is very similar to that with a series of sprawling villa with a series of
very interestingly shaped room spread across the terrain,
interacting with nature adjust as they did at Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
very much a countryside villa.
And I think Hadrian's villa,
clearly the main model as we walk through this accident metric view,
you see,
we enter on the western end.
At one,
we see a horse shoe shaped,
a vestibule with columns all around this villa,
just like Hadrian's villa activity does have a lot of columns.
Uh,
we see those here.
Then you make an abrupt right into this passage way here at uh,
two,
a then into the peristyle court with columns all the way around a,
a,
a pool in the center and interestingly shaped pool in the center and then a
series of living spaces,
uh,
to either side.
On the A to c we see a,
uh,
a transverse,
Carter,
uh,
which is very important because it links of various parts of the villa to one
another,
but it is always also very decorated with mosaics,
many of which you are preserved.
And I'll show you those in a moment.
Two D,
uh,
with its niche at the end,
probably a kind of audience hall,
uh,
three is where the private compartment is for the emperor and you can see that
that too is fronted by a small horseshoe shaped area.
Then over here at four we see a try lobe dining room,
the main dining room of the house with the triple lobes and then down below a
four court for that that is oval in shape.
So it's a very interestingly shaped rooms,
uh,
and uh,
where we see a combination of the interest in curvilinear shapes just as in
Hadrian's villa and in the use of columnar architecture references to classical
Greece.
Over here at five we see several rooms very interestingly shaped again,
uh,
that make up the bath is a private baths,
of this particular place when can visit.
It's still today.
Parts of it are very well preserved.
We're clearly looking at the peristyle court with the pool in the center of it
right here.
Uh,
and again,
it is particularly well known for its mosaics.
We see a long card are here with those mosaics.
They depict primarily scenes of hunting.
And I show you a couple of those scenes here.
Uh,
and there's been some speculation if this was not Maximilian's that it may have
belonged to somebody who,
like those individuals who had the hunting bears that left us Modna were,
uh,
were whose work it was to collect,
to collect wild animals from Africa.
Africa is very close to Sicily,
collect them from Africa and send them to supply them to amphitheaters around
the world.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the,
even though most of these scenes are hunting scenes,
the most famous mosaics,
uh,
from the palace,
of Maximilian so-called at Piatsa,
our marina in Sicily are the so called Bikini girls.
And I show you the bikini girls right here.
And there's nothing like this mosaic anywhere else in Roman art,
but you can see why they're called the bikini girls.
And they are involved in all kinds of,
of athletic activities.
Uh,
one of them has received a,
a crown and a,
uh,
a palm branch for her,
for her excellence.
Uh,
this one is twirling.
Who knows what a,
here these two are playing,
uh,
passing,
playing ball.
And over here we see a woman on the left with her five pound weights,
uh,
working out.
So I mean,
this is,
this is probably the closest we get to.
I mean,
when does it,
this is very hard to interpret exactly what this means and what it's all about,
why it's here.
But perhaps we can see it as a kind of women's version,
uh,
to the mosaic that we saw in the baths of Caracalla with the famous athletes of
the day.
I mean,
perhaps these were famous women athletes of the day,
uh,
some of whom were good enough even to be awarded prizes.
But the,
the,
the jury is out on exactly what these were and why they're there,
but they're memorable.
These inimitable bikini girls and very,
very famous along with the Alexander Mosaic,
probably the most famous mosaic surviving from Roman antiquity.
Again,
I want to show you just very briefly to give you an inkling of a couple of more
palaces.
Uh,
one of these we know for sure is the palace of Glarus,
uh,
in,
the northern and the northern part of Greece.
The Palace of Glorious,
glorious,
as you'll recall,
uh,
was the,
um,
hilarious was a Caesar in the eastern part of the empire to Diocletian.
And I should mention,
I think I neglected to mention that Diocletian did by the way,
abdicate,
uh,
on the 1st of May in 305 had he voluntarily stepped down.
And when he voluntarily stepped down to new,
uh,
to the,
the,
the Caesars were elevated to Al Gousty and two new Caesars were chosen to new
Caesars were chosen,
uh,
and uh,
Gillary this became an Augustus and he built for himself this extraordinary
palace in northern Greece at Salonica.
And,
uh,
we can see from this plan and we have given you the data of it to two 97 to 305,
and I've given you a plan of it and you should be even the only part of it
survives.
You should be immediately reminded of palaces that we've already looked at,
not just today,
but in the past.
Think of diet of admissions palace on the Palatine Hill.
There's a hippodrome here just as dimensions palace had,
although dimensions palace,
it was used as you'll recall,
is a sunken garden.
We're not sure how it was used here,
but we think may have actually been used as a circus here.
Uh,
other rooms,
including an octagonal one with alcoves looking sort of like what rubbery is
designed again for dimensions palace on the Palatine Hill.
But up above,
we see just as Diocletian's palace and split,
it includes a tomb goal areas is also provided for himself and his afterlife,
uh,
by creating a round to a museum very much at the upper most part in this plan
from Ward Perkins.
And then very interestingly,
just like Diocletian's palace,
it's split.
You can see two major what looked like major roads,
colonated roads,
colonated streets that intersect in the second in the center,
just like Diocletian's palace.
And then in the center of that,
where they intersect,
there's a foresighted arch that I'm going to show you in a moment that's still
preserved.
Here's the plan of,
uh,
the,
of the tomb of delirious at his villa in this case round,
uh,
with radiating rectangular alcoves.
Uh,
you see it here.
It's actually very well preserved.
You as the interior,
uh,
showing again,
just as we saw at,
uh,
at the,
in the bowels of the octagonal room and the bads of Diocletian use of windows in
the second tier,
right at the base of the Dome,
uh,
rather than a,
an oculus.
Uh,
and we see that also very well in planned,
but there were two sets of them as you can see here.
Uh,
so they've abandoned the oculus in favor of these windows at the base of the
dome.
And then from the outside you can see that here they have used concrete faced
with brick bore the exterior of the structure which was turned into a church.
Uh,
and uh,
you can see,
uh,
some,
mosaics when it from when it was turned into a church and a minaret was also
added at one other point in time.
Here's a spectacular view of the tomb as it looks today in Salonica.
Uh,
you can see it here,
the exterior as well as its relationship along what would have been one of those
colonated streets with the arch,
which is in part preserve the arch,
the so called arch of hilarious.
You can also see from this view how similar modern Salonica is to modern Athens.
Same country,
same world war post,
World War II construction,
mostly residential houses of spot six,
seven stories with white and color with balconies.
As you can see,
here's a view of the art of the,
uh,
of the relationship of the tomb to the arch.
These two colonated streets,
uh,
that intersect.
And at that intersection,
the placement of the arch,
the arch was four sided so the streets could go underneath it.
Uh,
but it was also triple bade as you can see here,
a single central large bay to smaller bays on either side.
And then the peers,
uh,
decorated with sculpture that give us a report on the exploits,
the military exploits of Glarus in the eastern part of the empire.
These were delirious,
this wars hilarious.
His victories that are depicted here.
But we do believe that since it was one for all and all for one,
uh,
that it honored the tetrarchy as a whole as well.
And that there were niches that were placed somewhere on this arch that would
have had in them representations portraits of each of the four Tetra marks,
another view of the arch of delirious at Salonica where you can see it's
relationship even today to what was once the tomb of [inaudible],
uh,
here.
And,
uh,
a more detailed view of some of the scenes and how crowded they are with one
rectangular panel piled one on top of another and decorative motifs in between
them.
And if we look at a detail,
we see the usual things that we see on things like this,
the emperor sacrificing the emperor on horseback trampling,
Barbarian Enemies,
uh,
the emperor seeded with the other Tetra marks down here and with a host of gods
and goddesses.
And so again,
an honoring of Hilarious,
his own personal victories,
a Bot,
an expansion of those to include a reference also to the tetrarchy as a whole.
We're going to be talking next time about,
uh,
two men in particular,
a man by the name of Maxentius and Constantine,
the great concentrating,
the greatest I've already mentioned was the son of Constantia is Cloris.
Max Sanchez was the son of Maximilian.
So we see the generations continue and the sons of the tetrarchy also want to be
ted trucks themselves,
if not so ruler.
And we'll see Maxentius and Constantine do battle against one another in
Tuesday's lecture.
Uh,
but I just want to mention it.
We'll talk about Max inches in some detail next time,
especially his construction or hitting the beginning,
his beginning construction on a great basilica in Rome that Constantine
eventually finish the so called basilica of Maxentius Constantine or the
Basilica Nova.
But I want to mention just in passing today,
a villa about a villa that Max sent just built in Rome on the,
via Apia in Rome.
Uh,
just the round the circle and to show you that some of these palaces were still
there,
were being built in these,
in these capitals elsewhere in the world.
But we're still being built in Rome.
And we know that [inaudible] has built a villa in the early fourth century idea.
As I said on the VOP and rum,
there are some remains of it today.
I show you a general view of those here and a view from the air from word
Perkins,
I believe,
uh,
that shows you that part of that villa,
which is still preserved,
was another one of these hippodromes,
this circus.
And in this case,
we know that this circus was used as a circus that horse races took place here
and that was built to hold 15,000 spectators,
15,000 spectators to come out onto the Bia Apia,
uh,
to see horse races at Max [inaudible] villa.
We also know that this villa had a tomb that Max just provided for himself and
perhaps for his family as well,
uh,
inside his villa.
So we see this same idea that we've seen in the province is being used at Rome
in Rome concurrently,
a,
uh,
a tomb that is not all that well preserved,
but there is enough where we do believe it was a kind of mini Pantheon.
And I show it to you here in two restored views that give you a sense of what it
would've looked like.
That it was indeed a mini Pantheon,
that it was round that had had a traditional porch and the front with columns
and pediments,
deep porch,
freestanding columns,
single staircase facade orientation,
a dome does.
You can see here,
this one looks like it reconstructs and Oculus,
although I don't think we're absolutely sure that this structure had an Oculus,
which seems an unlikely thing to do with a too many way to have a opening in the
ceiling and rain coming of water coming into that tomb,
but numb.
But leaving that particular detail aside,
we believe it was in the form of the Pantheon,
a better preserve to him that I can show you that seems to have been quite like
it.
Uh,
is this last monument that I'm showing you today.
The tour day scabby or restored view that from Ward Perkins that,
uh,
was a tomb that was put up and around a d 300 on one of Rome's other major
streets.
The via Prajna Stena as I've indicated on the monument list.
Uh,
and once again,
we see this whole idea of the mini pantheon bid being used not as a temple to
all the gods,
but as a tomb,
as a tomb around structure with a traditional porch on the front,
rectangular pediment,
uh,
deep porch freestanding columns in that porch,
single staircase facade emphasis here.
Uh,
you also see interestingly enough that this one we know did not have an oculus
and you can see that they have put windows at the base to provide light.
These are not the usual windows that we've seen that we're RQ waited at the top,
but rather round windows sort of portholes,
uh,
into,
the,
this particular tomb up above.
You see the plan as in ward Perkins round with radiating alternating curved and
rectangular alcoves.
There is some controversy about the porch,
whether it had a regular,
complete rectangular triangular pediment or whether it had an RQ weighted
Lindell.
We're not sure,
uh,
various scholars have put forward a one view or the other.
But the last thought that I want to leave you with is that it's very interesting
to see these mini pantheons being used as tombs in late antiquity by the
tetrarchy and by others and if not many pantheons octo octagonal structures that
also look back to the past.
And I think that's important.
And it's a nice note to end on because it reminds us that when Diocletian and
the other tetrarchy come into Rome after the chaos of the third century Aad and
want to establish stability,
once again,
reestablish stability.
What did they do?
They look to the past,
they build buildings in the Roman forum,
but they also look to the great architecture of their earlier counterparts of
Caesar,
of the great leaders of the Roman past Caesar Augustus Hadrian.
They look to them,
they look to their buildings and they use their buildings as models to indicate
that they are in a line of,
they are in a line from those earlier emperors,
that they're just as much in control,
that they have brought stability back to Rome.
Uh,
and also to the empire as a whole,
which is why we see them building not just in Rome,
but also around the empire as they govern from the fringes as well as they
govern,
govern from the city of Rome.
Thank you all.
Have a good day.